foreign
Beatrice Auntie Kaplan is the fourth and
final lieutenant in the division's
pursuit of the main target stovepipe
she has been located on the streets of
DC and agents and now closing in
[Music]
Beatrice Auntie Kaplan with a
deceptively sweet and unassuming
presence of as a dark and dangerous side
that lurks beneath the surface
mocking the conventional expectations of
society Kaplan having no desire to have
children would often joke about a future
as an eccentric old cat lady
during basic training at the first
target practice session a new recruit
playfully gave her the name Auntie
shortly after this new recruit as well
as Kaplan would be involved in what she
called a reloading accident that would
ultimately claim the recruit's life
any doubts of whether the incident was
actually an accident would be cleared up
after she shamelessly sees the
opportunity to wield her Newfound infamy
insisting that everyone a dresser is
Auntie she sought to instill a sense of
fear and respect from those around her
and he showed no guilt or remorse for
her actions and instead used it as a
stark reminder of the ever-present
danger and mortality that haunted their
lives if they crossed her but also to
solidify her position of power and
dominance within the ranks
when she heard news about the true Sons
aligning themselves with the Black Tusk
she was most excited about the fact that
she would no longer go by the name hitty
officer Kaplan and instead have people
continue to refer to her as auntie
we're in position fully stopped in
awaiting orders General thank you Kaplan
Auntie right thank you Auntie no problem
General
about those orders continue to do
perimeters sweeps of all known division
control location s and look for any weak
spots or opportunities and if I find any
you want me to move in or report back
reserving report for now
Italia has a plan and we need to support
her vision
do we get to know what that vision is
eventually when the time is right we
still don't know who we can trust this
Alliance is too new and Lewis has
unfortunately brought too many people to
his side you worried about Bantam should
I be well is he still insisting you call
him Lieutenant Phantom yes it's like
switching teams just because you put on
the uniform it doesn't make you a part
of the team and if you won't even put on
the uniform how much do you really want
to be on the new team
right
Point yeah
permission to go off base why I want to
meet cursed in person
Mission denied I just need two hours we
can find a neutral place to meet why do
you want to meet him he reached out
wants me to help root out the rest of
the rats and Traders we're talking about
Bantam again no
Phantom's cute chicken [__] to do
anything he'll die before he grows the
balls to defy orders I don't know about
that he's harmless I mean unless you
order him to kill people then he's
actually pretty good at his job
but he's not one to get original ideas
and if a bad actor gets in his ear oh
well then yeah he can be easily
manipulated
you want me to keep tabs on him just in
case that might not be a bad idea but
quietly remotely don't let them know
you're watching that's the only way I
know how to watch
permission denied why worried I'll draw
too much attention need to stay on
Mission worried I'll get distracted or
something who knows
look forward to meeting you me too it's
a tree you were stationed in Germany
when this all went down
if
if you ever see combat before this I've
been deployed what's your number
before this
um 20 or 30
after 50 I stopped counting really yeah
too hard to keep track not for me what's
your number 372.
were you deployed before this
nope
went through basic and joined the guard
I never got to see any real action until
the jtf was activated
372 kills this year
that's impressive 371.
actually
these columns are just a continuation of
the conversations cursed was having with
Natalia she has asked kurz to get in
touch with Auntie and use her to help
weed out the traitors
these are all showing that Natalya
doesn't hold the true sons in
particularly high regard especially
after Captain Lewis jumped ship with a
large group of the true Sons
it also shows that Natalia continues to
have absolutely no confidence in General
Anderson he has been left completely in
the dark and now has her men going
around him in order to discuss plans
with certain true Sons
specific stove pipe I know about the
dirty bombs what about them your little
experiment here someone stole it and
used it in St Louis what experiment the
goddamn dirty bombs Natalya stovepipe I
have never approved experimental dirty
bombs perhaps the isolation is getting
to you
you're full of [__] Natalya I do not
appreciate your tone I don't give a [__]
get me out of here I'm done finish
setting up the base at Coney Island and
I'll send a relief team to finish your
mission in New York
we can sort out this confusion when you
get back to base
through this interaction we learn of the
location of stovepipe pony Island it
sounds like he is setting up a base for
an attack on New York City with all of
these past comms this season it appears
Natalia could be planning to use dirty
bombs on the city obviously stovepipe
isn't particularly happy about this and
chooses to call her out and who can
blame him everything we've heard has led
us to similar suspicions
one thing is for certain though the
disrespect he has shown there is no way
Natalya will let that slide
Auntie's downfall started with a tip
that reached the division agents
revealing her presence in Washington
DC's West End district with this
information in hand the agents embarked
on a mission to dismantle the true Sun
outposts progressing through until they
eventually find out that Auntie was
located on Roosevelt Island
the island stood as a daunting challenge
for the determined agents but undeterred
by the overwhelming odds they pressed
forward navigating the treacherous
landscape of the compound
the area had been heavily fortified by
the true Sons presenting a formidable
challenge for the agents to overcome but
step by step they would push through and
eventually close in on Auntie however in
typical division agent fashion they
would shoot first and ask questions
later
they actually didn't get a visual
confirmation on the target before
one-shotting something threw some
foliage
they would have to run to the other side
of the map to confirm it was her and
with this target down an all-available
Intel gathered the agents would be able
to move on to the main target stovepipe
though I hope her sister doesn't seek
revenge I don't think that fight would
go down in quite the same way
obviously when these final targets come
out the main target is then released
immediately after so there isn't really
any reason for me to speculate on
anything plus I think a lot of you are
waiting for me to hurry up and talk
about what we saw in the wrap-up of the
season so I won't waste your time and
I'll finish this one up quickly
I'm in the process of writing the script
on the final And all I'll say is wow
they definitely ended the season and
year four with the bang
anyway thank you very much for watching
and I'll catch in the next one extremist
malice extremely remedia
[Music]
[Applause]